[Music]
you've learned poi gunslingers now what
comes next drex here from drexfactorpoi
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow arts to benefit your
body and brain and today i'm going to
share with you my picks for what comes
next after you learned one of my very
favorite poi moves but before we dive in
i just want to give a quick shout out to
the friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to non-business friends
of the channel johnny howard and lane
mochinski thank you both so very much
for your support from my work and my
mission so stop me if you've heard this
story before you have spent countless
hours drilling and working towards a
trick and you finally got it down and
you're so proud but
what do you do after that do you go back
and learn another trick and go through
that process again you kind of feel
attached to the work you just did is
isn't there anything more that you can
get out of the work you've already done
why yes friend there is because it turns
out many of the poi tricks that we learn
have variations or other related tricks
that are relatively easy to get once you
have the basics under your belt and
that's what this series is for it's not
a tutorial it's not really a combo it's
what comes next and it's how you can get
more out of the stuff that you've
already learned and today's video comes
by request for nick von ashen and nick
wants to see me do a video on
gunslingers and i am absolutely frothing
at the mouth to get this one done
because until he requested it i didn't
know how badly i wanted to do this
gunslingers of course are a type of poi
spinning wherein we switch our grip so
that rather than holding on to the poi
handle we're holding on to the tether of
the poi that means that we've
effectively transformed a single poi
into a meteor and it means that suddenly
all the movements of the poi are going
way faster than we're used to now as
many of you know gunslingers have been
an integral part of my style now for
several years and so thinking about what
was important to me to learn after i got
those down has been a really fun
exercise and of course i am always down
to show more of a thing that i really
like so i'm going to start this one off
with something that is pretty basic but
trust me it gets to some place good and
we're going to start off just by
learning the basic gunslinger weaves now
if you already know how to do
gunslingers at all chances are you
already know how to do at least one of
these weaves there's a forwards thumb
lead two beat as well as a reverse pinky
lead two beat and aside from the fact
that they kind of like just let you hang
out in gunslinger mode before you decide
what you're going to do next they also
have the added benefit of setting you up
for one of my very favorite gunslinger
moves of all time namely if you have
mastered going back and forth between
your forwards thumb lead and your
reverse pinky lead you can also turn
this into a full flower how basically
you turn the transition back and forth
into a move that goes up and down fully
turning the entire thing into an
anti-spin flower namely a petal one if
you count both ends from a number two
pick we're also going to keep it pretty
basic and i'm going to suggest that you
learn how to do your spiral wraps in
gunslinger mode spiral wraps are an
absolute mainstay of poi spinning in
general but they take on even more
special significance with gunslingers i
would argue quite frankly that doing
spiral wraps is one of the reasons that
gunslingers were created in the first
place and you can't get around the fact
that they look incredibly catchy i would
honestly argue that spiral wraps are one
of the great staples of gunslingers
i mean the original combo with
gunslingers was literally just entering
into them doing the spiral wrap and
returning to a normal grip so it's kind
of baked into the pudding here it's also
a great exercise to learn how to do
these spiral wraps when your poi is
moving so incredibly fast and you're
having to really really quickly change
things on the fly which is going to be a
theme for the entire time you're playing
around with gunslingers so before i
share with you my number one pick i do
have a favor to ask because if you've
come this far it likely means that you
find poi intriguing and would like to
learn more about it guess what i make
lots of videos about poi whether they be
reviews flow sessions or what comes next
like you're watching right now so if you
could please go ahead and hit that
subscribe button ring the bell you know
the whole deal
this is going to help you make sure that
you see all of my poi videos in the
future so keep an eye out and of course
pretty please leave me your requests for
tricks that you would like to see me
cover in future installments of what
comes next i get all the ideas for this
series from those of you out there so
help me help you and now for my number
one pick of what comes next when it
comes to gunslingers yep this one's kind
of selfish but i have to give it to the
wrap entry without this i don't know if
i really would have gotten into
gunslingers like i have
so i consider there to be two primary
entries into gunslingers one is the wrap
entry that is the classic we all know
and love and the other of course being
the wrap entry where you wrap the tether
halfway around your hand before you
release the handle and re-establish your
grip in the middle it's something that
was first showed to me by cryptic
firecat years ago and it has become such
a staple of how i enter and exit
gunslingers that i just can't think of
gunslingers without it now there's
nothing wrong with doing the other entry
which i usually refer to as the slide
entry this is just another tool to have
in your toolbox and one of the things
that's really good about it is it takes
two beats to enter also you can
essentially do the same move in reverse
on the other side to exit back out of
the gunslinger it's eye-catching it is
definitely a staple of my style and i
wish i saw more of it out there so it's
my number one pick for what comes next
when you learn gunslingers
[Music]
what did you think of my picks did i
leave any out leave me a comment and let
me know what would you have put on a
list of what comes next after you learn
gunslingers this video would not have
been possible without the kind support
of these amazing folks right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along with the wonderful people
listed down in the description help to
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible do you like poi
content do you like tutorials do you
like reviews do you like what comes next
i'm on a mission to bring poi spinning
and flow arts to the wider world and
help people connect with their brains
and their bodies as creative individuals
so help me do it head on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up
there you can get early access to my
content as well as exclusive lessons
that are available only to my patreon
supporters so i'm hoping that you are
inspired to support this work so go and
please check that out thank you in
advance okay this was super fun because
i got to play around with some more
advanced stuff here and goodness only
knows
all the work that went into learning
gunslingers uh it was quite a lot to get
there and i was very very grateful for
being able to find things that were kind
of lateral movements once i got there so
hopefully this helps some of you out
there who are playing around with
gunslingers to do the same uh if you'd
like to check out more videos in my what
comes next series i will leave a link to
a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you're watching on youtube thank you so
much for watching get outside and flow
this weekend and i will see you with a
new video on monday
peace